how do i say hello world in japanese
and what about in spanish
well stay with me as we explore the
translation api to make our apps global
welcome to ai adventures where we
explore the arts science and tools of
machine learning
i am priyanka vergaria and today we are
talking about translation api
have you ever typed how do i say
tomatoes in hindi
in your google search i bet you have
well maybe not exactly that but
something similar right
then you have used google's translation
models
but what if you could use the power of
this translation model to
translate your websites and apps making
them
instantly usable across the world in
multiple languages
well that's where translation api comes
in it is a high quality pre-trained
translation model
that can automatically identify more
than 100 languages
and translate them you can easily
integrate your website or apps with it
using the rest api let's see how
first enable the translation api in your
project and create a service account for
authentication
make sure you provide the cloud
translation api editor role to your
service account
and generate a json key this will be
used to authenticate our call
i love cloud shell so here i'm using
curl from cloud shell to call the
translation api
where you can use the language of your
choice we authenticate the service using
the key we downloaded earlier
now let's say we want to translate the
weather is amazing today
into hindi here we are setting both
source
and target but the source is optional
since the api can auto detect the source
language
we pass this request.json file as a
payload with our http post request
to the translation api and we get the
translation
mossam aaj adbuddha this is great
let's try another example now google
cloud is
an amazing technology
even though this is technically a
correct translation
it still feels weird this is because
google cloud
is a proper noun and should not be
translated
in such cases where you have product
names company names and other proper
nouns
you would like more control over how
these specific
words are translated that's where
translation api's
advanced glossary feature comes in it is
essentially a custom dictionary that the
api uses to consistently translate your
domain specific terminology
here's how it works we create a glossary
file with samples of our source and
target language phrases
and save it in google cloud storage then
we make a translation request
using the glossary files now let's apply
this to
our example we create a glossary file
name it glossary.csv and you can also
create them in tmx or tsv formats if you
want
let's add some examples here google
cloud stays the same translation api
stays the same
while technology translates upload this
file to a gcs bucket
before we start using the glossary we
need to register it
and create a glossary id where in the
payload we mentioned the source and
target language
along with the location of the file and
now
we are ready to translate the text using
our glossary
and here we see the translation now
takes our glossary into account and
considers google cloud
as a proper noun so far we've seen text
translation for a single string
but what if you wanted to translate
multiple files in multiple languages
that's where the batch translation
feature comes in
it is easy upload the files you want to
translate into google cloud storage
request translations in multiple
languages
and then store the translations in
google cloud storage
let's see how this works i have this
sample text file
that we will translate in a few
different languages
we define our request body in the three
languages
spanish french and hindi provide the
path for the source and destination in
google cloud storage
then make a call to the api endpoint
with batch translate text
using our request body now let's go to
our google cloud storage bucket to see
our translated files
and they are available for us to use
in this episode we learned how
translation api works and tried some
advanced features such as
batch translation for bulk translation
needs and glossary for correctly
translating
proper nouns and product names i look
forward to seeing you on the next
episode of ai adventures where we will
explore
custom domain specific models using
automl
translation in the meantime if you have
enjoyed this video
click that like button and be sure to
subscribe to get notified about the
latest episodes
right when they come